you know i'm beginning to think that
these democrats may not
have our best interests at heart now i
i don't want to go out on a limb here
but it just seems to me
from everything they've been doing the
past few days and weeks and months and
well quite a while
that that the democrats actually don't
want our country
to be strong to recover to come together
to maintain law and order the most
recent example of this
came when democratic senator maisie
hirono was asked a simple question
will you condemn antifa will you condemn
the anarchists who are attacking people
and smashing in skulls and breaking down
windows
and setting the country on fire senator
ted cruz
posed this question to maisie hirono and
what did she do
she stormed out of the capitol we should
all
join hands and and denouncing
and whatever words you want to use
about violent extremism of all stripes
and i think we can all agree on that so
to constantly accuse democrats
of not caring about that is really i i
can only say that you you aren't
listening
so i hope this is the end of this
hearing mr chairman and that we don't
have to listen to any more
of your rhetorical speeches thank you
very much i'm leaving
well i appreciate the as always kind and
uplifting words of senator hirono
and i would also note that throughout
her remarks she still did not say a
negative word about antifa nor has any
democrat here
they instead engage in a political game
where they depend
you're welcome to say something negative
about antifa right now
oh she's welcome to say something
negative about antifa right now
but she won't instead she'll storm out
of the building
it's funny this is almost like the flip
of what the democrats say to
conservatives
they'll say say black lives matter and
republicans
who don't want to associate themselves
with a marxist organization say well all
lives matter they say but say black
lives matter well that's what the
republicans are doing here they say
will you condemn antifa democrats say
yeah we condem
extremists no no not extremists
generally do you condem
antifa and they can't do it they can't
do it because antifa
is the militant wing of the democratic
party this is the tactic
that conservatives are going to have to
do they're going to have to put all the
pressure back on democrats
to answer for their open contradictions
for their open calls to tear down this
country
we'll get into all of it i'm michael
knowles this michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show we got to get
to i think a
telling comment that we saw yesterday on
the youtubes this is from dc
says i'm a never trump republican i was
a never trump republican but now
i'm going to be voting for trump i have
told only my immediate family
yeah i do not fit the description of the
trump voter who is portrayed in the
media
that second line there i think is the
most telling which is i've only told my
immediate family i don't want to please
don't tell my boss i can't let anyone
know i think there are a lot more people
like this in the country
i think that in the last four years
nobody has switched from being pro-trump
to voting against trump some people
might not like everything he did some
people might wish he did a lot more
but i think trump could only have gained
votes
since 2016. he may have lost some
because people
aged out you know they're no longer with
us and he may have lost some because
democrats are going to try to cheat at
the election particularly with
widespread mail-in ballots which we'll
get to in just a little bit
but i don't see how he lost a whole lot
of votes how could he
when the left has become so radicalized
got a lot of evidence of that
we also before we get into it i have to
thank our friends over at rock auto
you know i'm not exactly
the most expert in auto parts okay i
know this will shock you so
when something breaks on my car which
has happened a few times unfortunately
in the past few years
when you go to a brick and mortar store
what happens you go in you say
do you have the part for my car and they
don't they
will then go online they'll probably go
to rockauto.com they'll order the part
then they'll charge you
twice as much don't do that don't play
that game rockauto.com
always has the lowest prices available
okay there
are no gimmicks here they just offer you
reliably low prices
it's family business serving auto parts
customers online for 20 years which by
my calculation is pretty much
as long as there has been an online go
to rockauto.com to shop for auto and
body parts
from hundreds of manufacturers the
catalog is unique and most importantly
it is remarkably easy to navigate
so easy to navigate even i can do it go
to rockauto.com right now
see all the parts available for your car
or truck right nolescanner wlas
in there how did you hear about this box
so that they know that we
sent you that is rockauto.com
i don't think these democrats have our
best interests at heart
i i think that probably is just common
sense these days
but i think we have to take it further i
think they have an active
open antipathy for our country i don't
think they like our country
i think we knew this 12 years ago when
barack obama ran for president
and he said he wanted to fundamentally
transform our country
now that he used high-flying rhetoric so
a lot of people didn't
didn't hear it then and no one wanted to
hear that barack obama didn't like the
country but it is simply a fact
that you don't want to fundamentally
transform things
that you like you wouldn't say that to
your spouse honey i love you i can't
wait to fundamentally transform you
well now it's a little less subtle now
you have democrats
openly cheering on anarchists you have
democrats
refusing to condemn these organized
violent street gangs and anarchists i
actually part of what the reason i'm in
dc is senator cruz and i sat down
with the acting secretary of the
department of homeland security chad
wolfe
what a name and we talked about this how
highly organized
it all is the violence in portland the
violence in other cities
they won't condemn it on the left and if
they won't condemn it i think the only
reasonable conclusion we can draw is
that antifa
these violent organized thugs are the
militant wing
of the democratic party just as in the
19th century
the clan was the militant wing of the
democratic party i'm not saying they
were synonymous
but there was a lot of overlap there and
the klan did things that the the
organized official democratic party
could not i think we have to say the
same thing today about antifa
because the democrats know that antifa
exists they deny that antifa exists
jerry nadler very prominent democratic
congressman
says oh that's just that's just
propaganda there's no such thing as
antifa
maisie hirono refuses to condemn antifa
at this hearing
on the on the violence in the streets
none of the democrats on the panel would
condemn antifa
what's so hard about it they harangue us
all the time to say black lives matter
which is an obvious statement that
everyone believes
because they want they want us to ally
with an openly marxist group
and frankly we do it you know we do it
when we when we
utter that phrase but the democrats for
their part won't
condemn antifa beyond that
they are now openly attacking the flag
this started with colin kaepernick
now it is widespread now it's everywhere
you've got members of the house of
representatives taking a knee
as a symbol of disrespect to the
american flag which is a symbol
of our country and by the way this is a
culmination of the progressive project
i don't think that this is some
outrageous outlandish
kind of slander or extreme rhetoric to
say that democrats don't like our
country very much
this has been the case for a hundred
years because the premise of the
progressive project
is that the country was really bad and
we're about to make it much better
it's the opposite of the conservative
project which says that our country
actually was pretty good
and and we're actually the ones who have
been kind of messing it up a little bit
but we we do want to live up to our
highest ideals
we've been talking all week about the
the baseline differences between
progressives
and conservatives one of those is pretty
simple
progressives think that things naturally
get better conservatives think that
things
naturally decay that's a big difference
progressives think because of the laws
of evolution and they'll they use these
terms explicitly when they talk about
charles darwin for instance in the
writing of woodrow wilson
they think that the order of nature is
for things to improve
but conservatives know that the order of
nature is things for decay
how can we figure out which one is right
well i'll give you a good example
head on out just go out into the middle
of the field somewhere and put up a big
white
picket fence and then leave that white
picket fence there
for two months or two years or two
decades i don't know
come back is the fence going to look
nicer or is it going to
look dingier dirtier decay fall apart
obviously the latter
leave a 25 year old hollywood model
look at a 25 year old holiday hollywood
model and then
two decades later look at that same
model have things gotten better if
things gotten worse with plastic surgery
in la
who knows but probably the order is
decay we all know
that that is the natural order but the
democrats the progressives won't believe
that
they think things are getting better and
so as things don't get better
as things remain basically the same they
have to denigrate
the past and that's what they're doing
this is true
at even the most moderate levels of the
democratic party
you you just saw yesterday that the
revolutionary
communist party has endorsed joe biden
now the revolutionary communist party it
sounds like some kind of
imaginary thing from a conservative
fever dream it's real i actually went
and i covered
one of their rallies not that long ago
and they had a rally in los angeles i
showed up they said america is terrible
we've got to defund the police we've got
to tear down this building
the rally was right outside of a police
station and then they said we've got
something really special
and they burned an american flag they
desecrated the flag
and i thought oh my gosh this is so
shocking well guess what that's now the
mainstream of the democratic party
the things that they were saying at the
revolutionary communist party rally
are now in the mainstream of the
democratic party no wonder that bob
avakian
the leader of the revolutionary
communist party is endorsing biden he
said this it was a tepid endorsement but
it was an endorsement nonetheless
biden is not better than trump in any
meaningful way except that he is not
trump and is not part of the move to
consolidate and enforce fascist rule
with
everything that means another person
endorsing biden angela davis a communist
terrorist
angela damas davis who is not on the
fringe of the left
she is welcome in the left she is
embraced
by the left she said the same thing i
don't love joe biden i don't think he's
a communist but he'll be easy to
manipulate and that's what we'll do
consider the double standard here
between the democrats and the
republicans
every time some fringe wacko
who has ever been a republican or a
democrat for that matter who has ever
said anything nice about trump
but let's say he's a racist or a bigot
or a terrible person
donald trump is asked all of us are
asked ad nauseam
do you condem do you disavow will you
condemn and disavow
and conservatives say yeah sure david
duke great example right how many times
was trump asked
do you condemn david duke he's asked
this dozens and dozens of times
one time he actually joked he said how
many times do i have to condemn david
duke
who cares about david duke david duke's
not a thing no
he has no influence whatsoever but sure
i condemn david duke
well what happens when the democrats are
asked to condemn the revolutionary
communist party
or a an open communist like angela davis
one they're not asked the question two
they won't do it the biden campaign has
said we welcome
anyone's support who will support our
campaign and oppose trump
i think what we need to do we're always
playing defense as conservatives maybe
there's something about being a
conservative that
that makes you you know want to kind of
be more passive and be on the defense
we've got to go on the offense in the
same way the left does constantly ask
them do you condemn the revolutionary
communist party do you condemn
angela davis do you condemn the three
founders of black lives matter who call
themselves open marcus do you can do you
disavow do you condemn do you disavow
see what they say to it because they
won't do it if they can't condemn antifa
which is killing people in the streets
attacking people burning down the
country
how could they do that what does this
mean
for the election in november
what do these endorsements mean well it
means that the trump campaign
in terms of the ground game is doing
better than democrats you wouldn't know
that from the mainstream media
the mainstream media are trying to tell
you that biden's poll numbers are doing
great he would win in a landslide if the
election were held tomorrow
well biden's poll numbers have been
sliding but that's not even the question
right now we're
still 90 days out from the election the
polls don't mean anything
unfortunately with national mail and
voting the polls might mean something
because people are going to start voting
much earlier than election day
at huge numbers i think part of that's
partly the reason why the biden campaign
is trying to push off the debates
and whether trying to push up the time
frame on which people can send in these
mail-in ballots
is because the more you see joe biden
the worse his numbers get the more decay
you see in that campaign
but just look at the ground game so far
that the trump camp has registered 100
000
new voters ahead of the election that's
more than the democrats and actually
since the 2016 election
republicans have gained 133 000 more
registered voters than dems
in pennsylvania 216 410 more voters than
dems
in north carolina and 87 000 more voters
than dems in florida
this is according to state data that was
just reviewed by axios axios is a
left-wing outlet
well boy axio has actually has been
gunning for the trump campaign for the
for the past week or so
but those numbers don't lie those are
important numbers in swing states
so no matter what the news media tell
you this thing that we were talking
about yesterday about the silent
majority
maybe people who are not lifelong
republicans people who are not your
typical conservative
they're coming out and they're getting
turned on to politics trump
pulled out a whole new range of voters
in 2016 that you hadn't heard from since
the reagan democrats of the 1980s
well those people might turn out again a
lot of trump supporters look different
than the media tell us they're supposed
to look in fact there was a group
it was called i think it's called blacks
for trump black voters for donald trump
marched through los angeles just the
other day
take a listen to what they have to say
those are the black lives that matter
not what nothing
no cover on old magazine behind the
temple though they died over on monday
no cover
on old magazine the 11 year old the
five-year-old
in his own in his own crib no no cover
or no magazine
talking about kids who have been killed
because of violence in the streets not
from the cops
but violence in the streets those black
very peaceful it's not you don't usually
see people wearing trump logos in the
middle of los angeles
supposed to say black lives matter
you're not supposed to be holding up
signs
that have trump's logo and more
importantly than that people are talking
about
you know the color of their skin or
they're talking about the trump logo
they have
but the biggest symbol that they're
carrying with them
is not the trump symbol it's not their
identity politics symbol
it's not their skin color it's the
american flag
that's literally the biggest thing that
they've got right it dwarfs the other
symbols
that's the key here i think some
conservatives believe
that you can divvy up the electorate in
the same way that democrats have
using the tactic of identity politics
which is you
you get people in a corner on their skin
color or on their
race or rather you know on their
nationality for instance or on
their sex or on their sexual orientation
or their sexual preferences or whatever
right and you just keep divvying these
up you invent whole new identity
categories
which the left has done systematically
since the 60s
and then you get them to embrace that as
their primary identity and then they'll
win
and some conservatives think okay well
if we just do that but we get those
groups to flip for
conservatives and republicans then we
can win but that's not how it works
the moment that you divvy up the
electorate that way and you make
some secondary feature people's primary
identity
they're already in for the left that is
the tactic of the left the tactic of the
left is
division the tactic is dissolution the
tactic
is turning one against the unity of
one's country
to fundamentally transform society so
the way that conservatives can do it
is by uniting people bringing them and
giving them a vision of the common good
that's what trump did
that was trump's appeal in 2016. he said
we all bleed the same blood
of patriots not black people should vote
for me
and but should consider themselves
primarily black people no it's
consider yourselves americans we're all
americans it's that
uniting message that is going to bring
people together the key here is not not
a blacks for trump sign
the key is the american flag the left
turns against the american flag the
right
must embrace it that's a choice and it's
a choice that's going to win out
if they can make that pitch through
november you know condoleezza rice made
this point
just the other day condoleezza rice was
doing an interview
she you know is probably the most
establishment republican
that you can get and obviously served in
the bush administration
but but even she was pointing out this
issue
of identity politics and she said
we need to get to a point not where
we're denying the black experience
not where we're you know minimizing the
role of jim crow or slavery
but at least where we don't tell black
people what
to think i'm someone who believes very
much
that we were we had a birth defect that
founded
slavery was a birth defect and it still
has an impact
uh when i hear people say oh i want us
to be colorblind no i actually don't
think we're ever going to be i don't
really care
if we're colorblind but i would like to
get to the place that when you see
somebody who is black you don't have
preconceived notions
of what they're capable of who they are
of what they're capable of of who they
are and she goes on to say
of what they think you know the the joe
biden example where he says
if you don't if you don't know whether
you're going to vote for me or trump
then you ain't black
right that's what uh the woman hannah
jones who's behind the 16-19 project
she said well there's a difference
between being racially black and
politically black
meaning if you're a black person and
you're authentically black then you have
to vote for democrats
and kind of laser rights is saying
that's terrible donald trump is saying
that's terrible too
but this politics of identity didn't
happen by accident
it is a great book just came out from
the heritage foundation scholar mike
gonzalez
it's called the plot to change america
you know actually i've got a copy of it
right here
the plot to change america how identity
politics is dividing the land of the
free i
i hosted with mike a uh a q
a and a discussion for the heritage
foundation i think you can find that
link online
i thought it was a great discussion mike
is a very interesting guy and what he
plots out in the book
is how left-wingers very
radical left-wingers open marxists for
the last
60 years or so have plotted with major
institutions such as the ford foundation
with the federal bureaucracy to not just
recognize a grassroots movement of
people
who are embracing their ethnic or their
racial identity
but actually left-wingers who contrived
those racial identities
so that they could divvy up the
electorate and move the country to the
left
great example of this was jorge ramos
jorge ramos who is the
journalist he's a reporter for univision
even though he's really a left-wing
activist
who that's his role as a journalist he
had an interview
yesterday with spain's el pais seminal
and he was asked this question do you
hope to see a latino president
what does jorge say of course not just
to see one but i hope i'm able to cover
one as a journalist
there are more latinos than
african-americans
they've already had one the next giant
step would be
to see a latina in the white house
now there's a lot buried in this this
one answer
obviously the interview goes on and
delves the project but just that one
answer
says one of course i want a latino
president
and why why does he think it's time for
a latino president well black people had
one
and so we should have one the the
implication here being
that the latino experience in america is
analogous to the black experience but
that's actually not true
it was the theory behind the creation of
identity politics
but it isn't true the theory behind the
creation of identity politics which
began in earnest in the 60s and 70s
and was undertaken by social scientists
in particular the ford foundation
is that you can analogize the experience
of
mexican people and south american people
and
asian people and women
and homosexuals and and every other kind
of group you can analogize those
experiences
to the black experience we're finally
seeing a little pushback on that
because that simply isn't the case i
mean there's a fundamental distinction
here right which is that for most black
people in america
their ancestors were brought over on
slave ships they did not choose to come
whereas for every other group their
ancestors
did choose to come to america just that
difference alone creates
incomparable an incomparable racial
situation in the united states to say
nothing then
of jim crow and the legacy of slavery
as we call it even the group the latino
group is a creation
of the 1960s and 70s when social
scientists in particular the ford
foundation
decided to try to push this racial
identity a homogenized
group identity for mexicans and south
americans
and even people over in spain or people
in the caribbean even
and call them hispanic initially or then
latino
this this identity group was rejected by
most hispanics or latinos
they didn't identify that way primarily
mexican-americans did not identify
as hispanic they and even today you
still see about a quarter of hispanics
or latinos would identify primarily
in that way other ways they would
identify is from their nationality or
either of origin or of immigration
identify as americans another example
arabs arab americans during the obama
administration they tried to make
a new identity group called mina
middle east and north africa mina
thankfully it didn't catch on
but the experience of arabs in america
is they've always been considered white
you look at someone like i don't know
someone someone who's in the meena
category would be like
mitch daniels former governor of indiana
blue eyed you know is now the president
of purdue does does he consider himself
an aggrieved racial minority no of
course not
steve jobs was he an aggrieved racial
minority no of course not
raises another question we're told all
the time that white privilege
exists but if white privilege exists
why is there a group of people seeking
to deny their white designation
and create a new identity politics group
linda sarsour one of the most
prominent left-wing islamic
people in the country she famously
started wearing her hijab in her
activism
because she said quote without the hijab
i'm just another
white woman she sees that this alleged
privilege is actually
a disadvantage that is a contrivance
this whole identity politics thing is a
contrivance
trump needs to run on the flag he's got
to run actively against this he and he
and he has been doing that for some time
but that's the message if he runs on the
campaign if he
if he runs on the flag as his campaign
the only way he will lose
is if democrats shut down the country or
try to steal the election in the mail
unfortunately
they are trying to do both there was an
amazing press briefing yesterday
with kaylee mcinany who makes our
national heart go pitter-patter
kaylee mcinning is there answering
reporters questions
and some of the questions don't really
see my question some of the questions
seem like activism like they were trying
to push her to do something and what
were the reporters trying to push her to
do
trying to push the president to do they
were trying to get them
to shut down not just some areas or a
hot spot with the virus
trying to get them to shut down the
entire country
this president's hard at work and he'll
continue to work you're doing everything
that you can possibly do when there are
still
waits for getting test results back when
you have declined to pose it
to impose a national mass mandate when
you're saying you won't shut down
the entire country again the president
of the minneapolis federal reserve he
said two days ago that he believed that
the only way to have a real
strong robust economic recovery
would be to shut the country down again
for a month to six weeks i know that
this idea of
short-term pain for long-term gain has
been
shot down before by president trump but
has has it been given
any more consideration given the recent
flare-ups across the country
these parasites are unbelievable these
left-wing journalists
hey so could you plea when i mean we
should
i look i'm not advocating one point or
another but we're gonna shut down the
country right
look there's short-term pain for
long-term gain
do we have any reason to believe a
complete shutdown of our country
would give us any long-term gain
some establishment liberals told us that
that's the case
to shut down until the election but do
we have any evidence that that's true
remember they told us 15 days to slow
the spread i think they told us that
about 15 years ago
they did they did tell us but i think it
was about 140 days ago
i don't think that led to long-term gain
in fact i think the lockdown has caused
much much much more damage to people's
lives to the country as a whole
than the coronavirus has so far
so do we have any evidence of what
they're saying no of course not
they just want to shut down the country
so there's not even a glimmer of an
economic recovery so people are kept
out of work so people kept frustrated
and angry so that trump gets blamed for
it
you know the whole premise has been from
the left
just shut down for 15 days it'll be
it'll be painful but then it'll all be
so much better
and conservatives get fooled by it but
what happens you shut down for 15 days
and it doesn't make it easier to reopen
it makes it easier to remain
shut down for months which is what
happened same thing with the masks just
wear the masks
and that'll make it easier to reopen
society let me ask you something as the
masks have become more common
has that led us to progressively reopen
society
no it's led us progressively to shut it
down even more
and now they say let's just shut down
the country for it'll be really quick
it'll be like four weeks
and then we'll reopen it'll be we'll go
like gangbusters fool me once shame on
you
fool me twice shame on me fool me three
times what are we even doing
shame on the whole country if they fool
us that many times
they're doing it to cheat the election
and at the same time when they say shut
down that is the pretext
to have national mail in voting even
though
in in fleeting moments of honesty the
left-wing news media have admitted
the mail-in ballots don't work we'll get
to that in one second
we'll get to nancy pelosi's novel
coronavirus cure
it seems that nancy thinks that puffing
on the old peruvian parsley is gonna
help you
it's gonna help you uh recover from
coronavirus you're not allowed to talk
about hydroxychloroquine
but if you're uh if you're talking about
that old those old jazz cigarettes you
know that old hippie oregano then
apparently that's gonna help uh we'll
get into all of that first though got to
thank you
thank you for heading over to the
michael knowles show youtube channel we
like that you're on the daily wire
youtube channel that's great appreciate
it we'll give ben those clicks but it's
also good to go to the michael knoll
show youtube channel
uh we've got some some great stuff it's
also where we pick out the comments to
feature during the show so don't miss
that over there
also all access you know is our uh most
exclusive
membership tier so uh head on over
and join all access if you haven't
already you will get early access to new
daily wire products like our new limited
edition
baseball bat in collaboration with
pillbox bat company handcrafted here in
the united states
emblazoned with the daily wire logo this
run of bats will be engraved with the
individual number in the order they were
produced
from 1 to 100. if you want to do that
you've got to be a member of all access
that's the only group that can that can
get the bat
text the keyword baseball to 83400
to purchase your collector's edition bat
also get 20 off all access right now
with coupon code access that is baseball
text it
to 84 300 and use the coupon code
access head on over to daily wire we'll
be right back with a lot more
we've got breaking news one of the
mainstream media networks
has been honest for a change and they
admitted
in a very rare moment they admitted that
the mail-in ballots
are not working listen to the report
tonight six weeks after the new york
democratic primary congressional
candidate suraj patel
doesn't know if he won or lost because
election officials have yet to announce
a winner
it was just a complete mess of a system
the reason
10 times more new yorkers a whopping 1.8
million
requested absentee ballots than did four
years ago
experts tell nbc news new york election
officials
were woefully unprepared governor andrew
cuomo had tried to make the process
easier by sending postage paid
envelopes with all requested ballots but
that ended up
backfiring because to be counted ballots
need to be postmarked with a date
something the post office doesn't
usually do for prepaid
metered mail so those ballots thousands
of them
were not counted thousands of ballots
not counted and that's not a dummy
experiment
those are real ballots that were not
counted you saw the experiment though
from that that local news affiliate in
philly
they mailed out 100 fake ballots to a
p.o box
and they got a couple birthday cards so
i don't know i don't know what what
happened to some of the other mail
they got some mail that they weren't
supposed to get a lot of it lagged
behind
by four days even over a week and then
three
of the 100 ballots gone permanently they
just didn't get them
well three out of 100 is three percent
80 to 100 million people expected to
vote by mail in november
it's a lot of votes do you think three
percent could swing an election
of course it could are we really willing
to stake
our election the integrity of our
elections
on a system that we now know doesn't
work we know it doesn't work in theory
by experiments
we we know that it doesn't work in the
actual practice of voting for real
candidates
but that's what the left is pushing for
it's also going to create this problem
where
on election night you're not going to
know who won because usually the
absentee ballots you know people who are
too
frail or elderly to leave or people who
are traveling who are abroad
they send in their absentee ballots but
the elections are so rarely close enough
that the absentee ballots really matter
that they just don't get counted or by
the time they get counted the winner has
already been announced
well that won't be the case if 80 to 100
million people are voting by mail
in addition to all the other problems
that creates we're not going to know on
election night who won
which is what the left wants because
it's kind of a win either way for them
either they can cheat it
at the mail-in ballots or they can
create this
this scene of president trump the
fascist
refusing to concede the election never
mind that the was the left on the left
actually conceded an election on
election night hillary clinton didn't do
it in in 2016
al gore famously didn't do it for a very
long time after the 2000 election
so that's the scene they're going to
create either way they win because it it
will fulfill the image that they are now
concocting or they can just outright
steal it
it's a real a double standard going on
here it's a it's a it's a tough
situation
they've backed us into the one thing we
know though is the arguments they're
making on the surface
are not to be believed they are
disingenuous arguments
they don't have the best interests of
the voters they don't have the best
interests
of our country at heart and you see this
every so often you see the obvious
hypocrisy
for instance when when the left says you
can't go to church you're not allowed to
leave your home
but you are allowed to go and protest
for blm you're not allowed to go to your
grandma's funeral
but we can have 100 000 people go to
george floyd's funeral or john lewis's
funeral for that matter
you say well how come what is the virus
that smart that
that uh analytical that it can decide
it's it's only gonna go
to the conservative events and it
affects people of course not pelosi's
making this argument now so nancy pelosi
as as the senate is debating the covid
relief bill
decides to cram in a bunch of handouts
for the marijuana industry
and and one of the arguments she's
making is that marijuana
will help you to recover from
coronavirus
take a listen to republican senate
majority leader mitch mcconnell cocaine
mitch
tearing it apart speaker pelosi is still
agitating for strange
new special interest carve-outs the
marijuana
industry and even claiming they are
covered related she said that with
respect to this virus marijuana is quote
a therapy that has proven successful
you can't make this up i hope she shared
her breakthrough with dr fauci
hello dr fauci yes it's nancy i just
want to let you know
i've got the solution i've got the cure
now meanwhile
the leftist is telling doctors
physicians
epidemiologists virologists that
if they talk about their own personal
experience with hydroxychloroquine
over the past several years or decades
even
that is dangerous medical misinformation
when doctors say that it's worked on
their patients that has to be banned
from social media
and if anyone does post it to social
media their accounts will be banned from
social media
you're allowed to say that but nancy
pelosi is allowed to say that marijuana
cures coronavirus
that's which obviously is not true but
even if it were true
an outrageous double standard it would
seem to me the left does not want this
thing to get better
i know in the olden days when the left
pretended that they loved america and
loved our country and they were they
were the true patriots
we were not allowed to question the
patriotism of the left
but i think since they've uniformly
started cheering desecration of the
american flag
we're finally allowed to question it
well the same thing goes with this
lockdown
this lockdown is killing people the
lockdown
is killing people through for through
just destroying livelihoods first of all
through what what we are seeing as
increasing rates of not just suicide but
violence in the streets
and through drug addiction and through
all of the pathologies
that accompany 50 million people being
thrown out of work
the democrats don't care they're willing
to take that hit
on the country one because it's not
going to really affect them but two
because they think it'll help them win
in november
even bill maher who's a kind of moderate
left winger moderate liberal
he he said this months ago he said yeah
i think we should have a recession
he was con he was condemned for it he
was criticized for in public because
they said you know you don't want to
ruin people's lives just to win an
election and he said yeah no
i do i think it would be better for
people to have that short-term pain you
know of
getting thrown out of their jobs for the
long-term gain of getting rid of donald
trump and now we're even seeing this on
hydroxychloroquine right you've got very
respected
doctors that yale epidemiologist in
newsweek that group of
doctors that gave the press conference
in washington saying that there's a lot
of evidence that hydroxychloroquine
helps
well if hydroxychloroquine works if that
yale epidemiologist is right and
we've got the cure we've got the
treatment then we could just give it to
people and reopen the country right they
can't have that
they don't want us to reopen the country
even some schools now that are setting
dates school systems that are setting
dates to reopen are are saying that
they'll reopen on november 6th
they'll reopen the first week after the
election they're not even
trying to hide it anymore and in the
midst of all of this in the midst of
this pressure
the trump campaign which is doing a lot
better these days they're still
they still don't see what's going on
they're still making some missteps
the the clearest example of this was a
fundraising letter from the trump
campaign
that just came out yesterday the letter
says friend
i know how difficult the past few months
has been you know blah blah blah give me
money please
please you know that's the implication
at least
but the explicit message is i'm writing
to you now not to ask for a contribution
but to ask for your help
we're all in this together and while i
know there's been some confusion
surrounding the usage of
face masks i think it's something we
should all try to do
when we are not able to socially
distance from others i don't love
wearing the masks either
masks may be good they may be just okay
or they may be great they can possibly
help us
get back to our american way of life
that so many of us have rightly
cherished
before we were terribly impacted by the
china virus my feeling is we have
nothing to lose and possibly everything
to gain so put on the mask
i don't know who i don't think trump
wrote this email himself i don't know
who authorized it it's a bad idea
it's a bad idea i'm not even telling you
this if you want to wear a mask fine go
ahead and wear the mask i don't really
care
i don't think trempel needs to send out
the opposite email which is don't you
ever wear masks masks are terrible
i think he shouldn't take the bait i
think he shouldn't take the premise
because his ideas the masks may be good
or great or wonderful
there's another option they can be
harmful to our
culture and to our politics because the
premise here is
the masks will help us reopen and i
think we've seen they won't
they will be used as evidence as a
symbol
that we are not yet ready to reopen and
that we need to remain closed
because the masks rather than make
people feel safer actually make them
more nervous
they make them look at their fellow
citizens as walking piles of germs
they are they are an evidence a buttress
for this idea that we've all got to lock
down because this is super duper serious
we've never seen anything like this
before
even though the coronavirus pandemic is
less deadly than pandemics we've seen
in the last century where we didn't lock
down the economy this is
a fundamentally political difference not
a medical or scientific difference and
the trump campaign
i don't know why but they're buying into
that that left-wing
symbol and that left-wing premise not a
good idea they're doing it again
with the rnc with the republican
national convention
first the convention was going to be in
charlotte then then north carolina shut
that down
then it was going to be in florida for
whatever reason they shut that down
now it looks like there's not going to
be much of a convention and and
president trump seems that he's going to
accept his party's nomination as the
2020 nominee
in private or in a little speech from
the white house or something like that
another big mistake
i get it it's very hard there are lots
of restrictions and people are afraid of
the messaging here
the trump campaign messaging cannot be
to take the democrat bait
to be on defense to acknowledge that it
was wrong about the men it wasn't wrong
about the masks it wasn't wrong about
the country the only way it was wrong
about the country is that they they
bought into the lie that we had to shut
it down
and that we should still be shutting it
down you've got to run against the
shutdown the shutdown
is the democrats campaign it's how they
want to steal the election
through the mail in voting it's how they
want to suppress
your vote it's how they want to keep
a lid on this economy they're open about
it at this point
you've got to run against the shutdown
and yet the trump campaign won't do it
you know the trump campaign
when it's just trump he seems to have
great instincts here
but they they keep on they keep on
making the misstep
of allowing the left to dictate
the terms of the debate nowhere did you
see this more clearly
then in an interview he just did some
clips of it had been released
with jonathan swann a very sharp
interviewer
who was interviewing with axios on hbo
just take a listen to a dispute they get
in over the covid numbers
take a look at some of these charts i'd
love to we're going to look
let's look and if you look at death yeah
start to go up again well right here
the united states is lowest in
numerous categories we're lower than
the world lower the lower than europe
in what in what take a look
right here here's case death
oh you're doing death as a proportion of
cases i'm talking about death as a
proportion of population that's where
the us is really bad
much worse than south korea germany et
cetera you can't you can't do that you
have what kind
you have to go by you have to go by
where look here is the united states you
have to go by the cases the cases why
not as a proportional population
what it says is when you have somebody
that has where there's a case
oh okay the people that live from those
cases it's surely a relevant
statistic to say if the us has x
population and x percentage of death of
that population
versus south korea by the cases so what
we're what we're listening to in this
debate
is not a debate over science it's a
debate over narrative right
what what president trump wants is to
talk about the
death rate by cases by people who
have tested positive for the virus and
what percentage of them are dying which
is a very relevant statistic
what jonathan swann wants to talk about
is death rate as a percentage of the
whole u.s population
and then he's comparing the u.s
population to south korea for instance
and the the obvious answer here is the
populations are not comparable our
political traditions are not comfortable
our geography is not comparable
our political system not not comparable
and and so
there there is just going to be a
progression of the virus in america even
dr fauci told us we're not going to get
hurt immunity even with a vaccine so the
virus is going to spread and you've just
got to deal with
how you can keep the deaths as a
percentage of cases
down that's the point president trump
was making though
i think in the heat of the interview he
he wasn't quite making the argument as
quickly or concisely as he should
then you have jonathan swann saying yeah
but okay that number makes you look good
so i want to use the number that makes
you look bad
it's a fight over the narrative and it
raises this question
one why is why is the president even
putting himself in a situation where the
left can dictate the narrative
why is president trump doing an
interview with axios on hbo
not exactly a friendly outlet frankly
chris wallace on fox news is not a
friendly outlet
so why is he putting himself in that
situation
doesn't make a whole lot of sense i'll
give you
probably the most extreme example of
this there's a big debate that broke out
on twitter the other day
the debate was over whether two plus two
equals four or two plus two equals five
i'm not joking
this was a this was trending for the day
people were actually arguing
and the left was arguing that two plus
two can equal five
which is exactly what the totalitarian
regime in george orwell's 1984 says
they say two plus two equals five and
they force
the protagonist winston smith to
acknowledge
not even just the two plus two equals
five but the two plus two equals
whatever the party says it is
and this all began because uh a meme
maker posted on
on twitter he says woke woke minnie's
two plus two equals four
a perspective in white western
mathematics that marginalizes other
possible values
it's just a joke because left wingers
have been saying that objective
reason and hard work and even
mathematics is a western white concept
and
people of color should reject that
should reject that idea
right people of color this this way to
analogize through identity politics
the experience of all other people with
black people in america even though
obviously
as we discussed earlier that doesn't
make any sense but then you had
people on the left actually defending
the idea that two plus two equals five
and without going into
the the tediousness of their silly
arguments they said look numbers
they're just symbols right so we can
make the symbols mean whatever we want
the symbols to mean
if we want if we want two to really be
two and a half
then okay then two plus two equals five
because two is two and a half and two
and half plus two and a half is five
and five can be banana and people do
gobbledygook right that the words and
the numbers that we're using they're
just symbols and they have no
no relationship to anything real that's
a left-wing point of view that's a
progressive point of view that we are
not bound by anything real including our
human nature
we can change anything we can we can
change
lies damned lies and statistics right
these numbers don't mean anything at all
all they have to do is fit
our narrative and our narrative is is
whatever we will
our narrative to be right this another
big difference here between the right
and the left the
left believes that they can construct
the world
based on nothing more than their own
unfettered
imagination and the right conservatives
know that's not possible there's
something that is
enduring it's called human nature
there's reality right the great
conservative constellation that reality
reasserts itself in the end
this debate over whether two plus two
equals four or two plus two equals five
or can equal five that is at work right
now in this
campaign do we want to maintain anything
resembling
our our reality or do we want to toss it
all aside
literally burn the country to the ground
burn our principles to the ground and
reconstruct them on the antagonistic
imagination
of the democratic party now that's
working at all levels right now on the
left
in the media in the the so-called
experts and the social scientists
and all the way up to their presidential
nominee who is endorsed
by the most radical anti-american people
in the country
and whose support he won't disavow those
are the stakes of the election we'll see
it in november will two plus two equal
four
or will two plus two equal whatever the
democratic party tells you it is
those are high stakes i guess we'll have
to wait and see get your mailbag
questions and i'm michael knowles this
mike and all show i'll see you tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies
executive producer jeremy bourie
supervising producers mathis glover and
robert sterling
technical producer austin stevens
assistant director
pavel wadowski editor and associate
producer
danny d'amico audio mixer robin
fenderson
hair and makeup nika geneva production
assistant
ryan love the michael knowles show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire
20 20. if you prefer facts over feelings
aren't offended by the brutal truth and
you can still laugh at the insanity
filling our national news cycle
well tune in to the ben shapiro show
we'll get a whole lot of that and much
more
see you there